prices on the rise indeed americans
feeling the strain as inflation hits a
40-year high of close to 8 percent now
the federal reserve is stepping in and
is expected to raise interest rates this
week for the first time since 2018. what
does it mean for your wallet as you can
see right here in the big studio we got
the host of making money on fox business
charles payne charles good morning to
you
why is the federal reserve going to jack
up interest we're trying to slow down uh
the you know the economy that's
typically what they do these interest
rate hikes if you can think about it as
speed bumps uh and the reason why it's
sort of controversial now is first of
all they should have put them in a long
time ago uh secondly it's it's rare they
do it under conditions that we have
right now again it's usually when the
economy is hot and accelerating we're in
an economy now arguably that's
decelerating uh and so there it's it's
another experiment if you will uh that
on the on a part of the federal reserve
in part because right they should have
probably taken his action at least a
year ago at minimum um
were you drinking your coffee when the
white house essentially blamed
vladimir putin for the putin price hike
the the inflation was at a 40-year high
before the invasion and now they're
blaming putin well they blame putin they
blame greedy corporations uh the trump
card expired and then over the weekend
apparently they started blaming their
own voters so
so i mean it's like you know
i guess when you get to the bottom of
the deck of the blame card the last one
is like blame the people that put you in
office they don't care uh you know it is
sort of despicable because
they're listen
a lot of things factor into inflation
but arguably that 1.9 trillion dollars
was completely unnecessary the so-called
covert relief act the american rescue
plan which by the way had its birthday
last week happy birthday the only thing
that's happened since then is prices
have gone absolutely through the roof
right and all of those gains last month
all the wage gains were erased people's
real wages were down 2.6 year-over-year
okay so you can see right there gas
hotels stuff is just through the roof
you know and one of the things that
my wife and i noticed when we go to the
grocery store sure the prices are up it
just seems like everything is a dollar
more or what a company is doing is
they're putting less stuff in the
packages yeah a big news story came out
over the weekend oh doritos that they've
taken five chips out apparently that
happened a year or two ago but you're
wha you were talking to your wife yeah
research department about this segment
and she went she went to the pantry she
went to the pantry yeah she said you
know what so my sister-in-law came by
the house friday with this with this
with this tuna fish she was really
pumped she said it was a few pennies
less okay my wife went to the pantry and
said yeah but check this out
commensurate
the price didn't go down enough to
offset how much less tuna fish you're
getting so i mean people see this every
day people see this all the time this is
what you live with and i ironically i'm
not sure how the federal reserve
even accounts for that this is inflation
in real life this is what happens your
money goes a lot further a lot less
further rather and and you get fewer
things and people realize this so on
friday we had the consumer sentiment
number out right it was so awful in fact
it was at a point that is always uh it's
always correlated to recessions and you
know listen i don't know what the white
house plans to do about it the blame
game isn't working independents six
months from now they see things a lot
worse democrats see thing on things a
lot worse and forget about republicans
so the american public is united on one
thing when you give them this and tell
them it's this they say it's you know
what was that there was a phrase they
used in the last segment three letters i
forgot
you can make chicken salad
something like that yeah all right
charles we're going to be watching you
over on making money with charles payne
two o'clock this afternoon over on fox
business sounds good thank you sir hi
everyone i'm brian kilmeade i want you
to do me a favor i want you to click to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not gonna miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
fox you can get it all here on youtube
so subscribe right now